well I welcome this U-turn but the
unfortunate truth is this conservative
government is in complete chaos uh I
don't think the chancellor has The
credibility to make all the changes that
are needed and I think he has to go and
I think that would really restore
confidence
they realized they'd made a mistake and
surely by owning their mistake they will
gain more respect not only from the um
British people but also from the markets
but I welcome the U-turn but the
chancellor saying today that he was just
a distraction from the rest of the
package and the whole plan he says is
okay that's not what little Democrats
think and I don't think that's what many
many people think your commentators
today have been pointing out quite
rightly that the 45p was only a small
part of the overall package if you look
at things like The Cutting corporation
tax that's worth 18 billion pounds a
year much of which is going to the big
Banks and to large corporations uh
liberal Democrats wouldn't make that cut
then refusing to do the windfall tax
properly which is leaving tens of
billions of pounds on the table which is
just going to the large oil and gas
companies so there's money there which
if the chancellor and this government
could completely change approach that
money could be used to make sure we
weren't having to borrow so much and
that would mean there'd be less pressure
on people's mortgages and millions of
families are struggling with their
mortgages and plus there'd be some money
left over to ensure they weren't cuts to
the Health Service and we could actually
help those who are really really
struggling this winter so the
government's uh plan such as it is is
totally wrong in my view this is a
welcome change but it's a small change
we need a far more radical overhaul of
the budget we needed soon and we needed
to be done in a transparent way and I
come to the conclusion regrettably that
I think this Chancellor can't deliver
that
it's about Collective responsibility as
we're often told but if the cabinet
didn't know about it how can they be
responsible
well you make a fair point okay that's
why I think the chancellor should carry
the can and the obviously questions
about the Prime Minister too but the
chancellor uh the Prime Minister told us
yesterday he made this decision I think
therefore uh he's right to u-turn on it
but the whole strategy that he put
forward to Parliament I think is wrong I
think is quite dangerous actually you
know I'm really worried as we go towards
this winter that there are millions of
struggling families millions of
pensioners huge numbers of businesses
who will really be in trouble and I
don't think the government have provided
sufficient help I don't think they've
provided the right type of help just the
time not only were they cutting taxes
for the rich but they're cutting tax for
the largest banks they were cutting tax
for the biggest uh corporations they
were letting the oil and gas companies
off uh paying off their fair share and
by doing that they've not controlled uh
borrowing that has put a pressure on
interest rates they've not provided the
level of help that could be provided so
I'm afraid it's quite an ideological
approach from the conservative
government and I think what our economy
needs what our people need is a proper
plan a proper economic plan which is
fair and which would actually get the
growth that we need I mean that's the
irony they say this is all about growth
but I'm afraid it's got so many flaws in
it it's actually going to undermine the
prospects for the British economy
um now the chancellor has already been
asked this morning whether he should
consider his position he says no what do
you think
well let's remember 24 hours ago the
Prime Minister was saying that the 45p
rates would stay that that cut that they
proposed would stay and they've you
turned dramatically in 24 hours I think
the chancellor really needs to consider
his position he has to go and he may be
saying he's staying today but a day they
used to say weeks along type in politics
a day is a long time in politics and I
think he he must go by the end of the
day
I mean I'm reading on uh social media
that his right hand man who I was
chatting to on the I'm not sure he'd
call it a chat but I was speaking to you
on the program
um in the last hour suggestions that you
know he's he might well be the full guy
he was the one that came up with the
paper that suggested that this was a
good idea and even as part of my
interview he still said it made economic
sense
um what do you think
well it's very unedifying isn't it
they're each blaming each other
yesterday the Prime Minister blame the
chancellor chances blaming his Deputy
this shows my central point this is a
government in chaos it's politically
unstable which is bad of itself it's got
the wrong economic ideas the fact that
he was trying to defend it still shows
how completely out of touch they are and
this is my feel if you have a gun that's
out of touch that takes people for
granted that doesn't give people the
Fair Deal they deserve you know people
going to work doing the right thing
getting up you know educating the kids
looking after neighbors you know people
are trying to do the right thing but
they've got a government that's not
behind them and it's clear by almost
everything that they say and they do the
conservatives have just lost the way and
you know I can't wait to the moment when
we can get them out of power in an
election but in the meantime the people
who've been responsible for this should
go and need to clear up the mess I don't
think they should be holding their
conference at the moment because you
shouldn't be going to cocktail partners
and sipping champagne they should be
back at the desks they should be putting
this right they should be coming to
Parliament and and showing that they've
changed fundamentally and the fact that
they they won't and aren't I think is a
is extremely bad for our country but
rather isn't this democracy in action
aren't we seeing
um the government reacting to their back
benches who um they wouldn't allow this
to get through Parliament along with the
opposition uh parties who also would
have voted against this so as a result
the government has listened
well it's all internal Tory Party
politics but it's not proper democracy
that should happen in the House of
Commons they should come and be
accountable to uh MPS across the country
of all political parties and All Views
now our country needs to come together
we need a strategy that can unite our
great country
a country that uh has so much potential
and is being let down at the moment by
this government and the one of the
reasons why people are protesting why
people are alarmed anxious frankly
terrifying in some cases it's just they
just feel that there's this Gap at the
top and they feel that the Prime
Minister the chance of the whole
conservative cabin there doesn't get it
or if they get it they don't care and
that's not good enough
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us